hola
[Música]
cerramos los ojos
concentración profunda en álava
tenemos pensamos
no no no
con los dos costados por favor ya van de
la mano con los siguientes preguntas
quien daniel ha sentido miedo
en el mismo
quien de aquí ha dejado el miedo
sin abra los ojos con tenemos
[Música]
cuanto más gente que cada organización
yo viví invadida por el miedo
miedo a el perjuicio a mi familia
acción
si pienso en mí en 29 años estoy
intentado árboles
[Música]
y yo
alegre el general tuvo una infancia muy
feliz
cuando las cosas comenzaron a cambiar
porque min igualmente de frente a las
otras niñas
a mí no me gustaban los niños como eres
[Música]
pero comenzamos
me dio miedo
[Música]
que se me pasó para siempre
y por supuesto jamás hablé de mis
sentimientos con nadie
en eso
por qué
quería pasar algo con su vida
comencé a sentirme que quería
pasa desapercibida
las cosas cambiaron cuando entré a la
universidad porque conocí a la primera
persona
y por primera vez parte de un grupo
por qué
con mis amigos y amigas pero tenía que
esconderme
de mi familia y diversión
pero bien
a los 21 años
[Música]
y dijo cosas muy dolorosas como que
tenía una enfermedad
qué más
sí
inglés
[Música]
intención personas no situaciones pero
jamás de idea
y también
[Música]
dos escuelas me sacaron por segunda vez
pero ahora estaba convencida
[Música]
por qué
iniciaba un programa por estar así
un día mi mamá invitó a una familia
cristiana a la casa
y ellos
cuando todo un sector yo estaba
sólo viendo
con todo
[Música]
por qué
yo tenía que seguir
durante los tres años que duró esa etapa
fui a vivir dos noches con la misma
familia cristiana
fueron 40 años
todos
intenté con todas mis fuerzas
regresé a mi casa llorando cansada
efigie cansada de mentir
y dejando tu esencia
[Música]
y quiero que seamos desconectamos de
nosotros mismos
creo que nos conociendo
bondadosos compasivos valientes y venden
que juicios
y en momentos en los que somos justos
la mejor versión de nosotros mismos
y con ese momento los dos
pues es sólo el momento que siempre
elegir ser
adiós
intenté 9
y al mundo que da por vencida de tuvo un
giro de 180 grados
[Música]
cuando el vidente
si te gusta más pero que había intentado
por qué
[Música]
cuándo
y
en la plática
y yo no
y aprendí que para conocerme
pongo
todas las experiencias que viví
de hecho un inicial encontrarlo en mis
propósitos de milagro
vivir tantos años intentando ser alguien
que no era
ayuda
- los ojos y funde tierra de artistas
una organización que
gusta
que los niños los niños los jóvenes y
comunidades enteras
en cuanto 2
de hecho en uno de los proyectos de los
artistas en oaxaca conocía el amor de mi
vida
y uno
que se sentó frente a mí
sentí esa conexión
y desde entonces
no paramos de hablar
queríamos cambiar el mundo juntas luz
enamorados
y el amor la acción
por 10 años
así que todo el que a césar me entrego
mi parte
sobre todo
qué
significa está el esfuerzo esfuerza
hacer mal visto con el dedo hermano al
ser empujada
y tiempo me incomoda
incómoda cambiar el estado de las cosas
es mucho más sencillo
contarnos la historia que queremos vivir
en paz y en tranquilidad y que por eso
no queremos causar problemas ni causar
tensión es mejor quedarnos callados
seguro que si queremos vivir aquí
estamos
tomar acción ya sabemos
es momento para mí nueve años cuando
y ojo
todos tenemos independientemente e
incluso con esos miedos que los tienen
y me ha dado
y a la larga misma
i
le dije
[Música]
en juicio
no
[Música]
el fuego
había conocido a una mujer con la
viciosa
me decía su mejor persona y yo a ella
y que con eso podía comprar
y entonces sucedió recortar más feliz
la razón
y lloramos el ideal
todos los órganos completamente
y me dijo
y por fin gracias mis amados elegida
am entiendo que los dos tuvimos que
pasar un proceso de aceptación
y el amor incondicional
hoy
[Música]
y que sin comprender
he decidido
[Música]
y les quiero invitar
a un viaje
y se invita a observar sin juicios
al tomar riesgos sin miedos
a son fieles a ustedes mismos y vivir
quisiera terminar con un último
experimento
y el de la mano
i
[Música]
en el intento
pero no
con todos
somos valientes
qué es
[Música]
no
[Aplausos]